You clicked on it, let's do this.
Hi guys and welcome to Tipsy Thursday, here on it'sGrace.
I went on my Tumblr and I asked you, guys what did you want to learn how to do today
and you gave me so many great  suggestions but I didn't take them and decided to do my own idea anyway.
But I read them and I appreciated them.
And I'm glad you spent time using your fingers to type.
Excellent use of time.
Except not at all, you could have done something way better with that time.
Today I'm gonna teach you how to dye your hair!
I impress myself.
By the time you're watching this video, I will be headed to Play List live. The Youtube convention in Orlando, Florida
and I decided that, beacuse my hair has a slight green tint to it, after dying it twice, I'm gonna dye it thrice.
And in doing, so I'm gonna teach you how to dye your hair. As if you couldn't read the f*cking direction for youself. But, hey, that's what the Internet's for.
First step to dying you hair is to put on clothes that you don't give a sh*t about getting f*ucked up.
Done!
Second to dying your hair, just letting yourself absorb the fact that you are voluntarily doing this to yourself.
You went out and you purchased the color and no one's holding a gun to your head or a feather to your feet. You are responsible.
Step three! Let's evaluate the hair color we've purchaced, but not for too long as to psyche ourselves out from what we're about to do.
I've purchased L'Oreal Paris Feria and it's called French Roast. Look at that girl!
So, if you don't know I recently just dyed my hair brown from blonde, though I am a natural brunette
and the first two times I've bought the hair color, it was the same color, and I bought it becuase the female on the box had brown eyes and brown hair
and so likened myself to her and I though "If we look I think similar this should be ok".
And then the ends of my hair turned out a little green.
I decided that I'm gonna go with a woman with green eyes and hopefully the ends of my hair will turn out brown.
Because that philosophy makes perfect sence.
Let me be your cult leader.
Next step is to analyse the emotional state that the model in the front of hair color box is in.
She's seems a little sleepy but sexy. Slexy.
Next step, open the box!
Oh! Treasures!
Soon you and I are gonna have the same hair color.
Next step is to read the instructions. They're probably good for you
Uh-oh!
Always wear protection.
Oh yeah!
"Be sure your hair is dry" Done!
"Unshampooed" Super done.
"And detangled"
Oh, well!
Being a girl rules!
"Twist-off shimmering conditioning developer cream bottle".
Put more adjectives please!
Boop!
Science, for ladies!
Aw!
This is some Breaking Bad lady sh*t right now.
"Welcome to you deserve a drink, I'm Grace--".
And basically what we're doing is we put it all over our f*cking head. Let's do it.
So, i'm gonna start at the bottom. 'Cause the bottom is what needs the color.
There's gotta be a better system to this.
I just do like uh... What was that game that you had when you were younger "Spin Art"?
I just do like a f*cking "Spin Art".
Oh, my eyes are watering!
That's how you know it's working!
When you start to look like someone accidentally pushed you in a pool when you weren't suspecting it, you know it's going well!
I can hear the collective cringe of every hair person out there being like "Why!?" and "Stop!" and also "Why!?" and "Please stop!"
What I do is, after my eyes have stopped burning little bit, then I get a brush and I brush my hair out to make sure that the mixture is evenly distributed.
The ripping noise means "that's ok".
Hair grows back.
What I do is, I take a hair tie and put my hair in the top of my head,  because this color has to sit for 25 minutes. Let's do it.
Did it!
Holy sh*t 25 minutes is passed-ish. I forgot exactly what time I started this, so this seems like enough. Now it's time to rinse it out of your hair.
Then you get out of the shower and you realise that nothing has really changed, except for your dirty, dirty T-shirt and the smell of your hair!
Even that guy stays constant.
Now it's time to dry you hair and see what actually happend!
(music)
Oh! Okay! It's dry! And it's not as green as it was before. It looks really red in this lighting but it doesn't in real life, I think I don't know, I haven't styled it.
Wait. Hold on.
I don't if I feel sexy as she feels, but I definitly feel sleepy!
Success!
I don't know!
The cool thing about dying you hair brown is that you start to look like you work in a coal mine
and then people will respect you 'cause you work very physically hard for very little pay.